hello grammarians hello Paige hi David
hello
' today we're going to start talking
about a different piece of punctuation
and that piece of punctuation is the
apostrophe kind of looks like a comma
but it's one that floats in the air
here's the ground
here's the word ground and if we say I
don't know Paige's dog Addie we're using
the apostrophe not shown to scale
obviously in one of its three different
applications so the apostrophe can do
three things
thing number one it can stand in for
missing letters so when an apostrophe
stands in for missing letters that's
called a contraction so what is that
what does that look like what is a
contraction look like in context so
another way to say something like I did
not eat the cookie is to say I didn't
eat the cookie so that that that
apostrophe there represents the Oh being
taken out and kind of everything being
squished together into this new word
didn't so did not gets together and then
we attach this apostrophe to show that
we've contracted or shortened or shrunk
these two words right page join me on
screen number two and let's talk about
thing number two let's go sure so the
second thing that an apostrophe can do
is show that something belongs to
someone's what we call possession so you
can use an apostrophe to say something
like that's David's cursive skull okay
it's true it's been in my family for
generations
but what what is what's going on here
what is what is this doing the same work
as so the sentence basically means that
curseth skull belongs to David this
first sentence that's David's curse at
skull is kind of just an easier way to
say that
so apostrophes can show contraction much
like we're also
doing in this part of the sentence as
well with that's because this is this is
a shorter version of that is David's
curse at skull but we're condensing that
or contracting that into that's but it's
also being used for its second purpose
here which is David's and this is what
we call the possessive or the genitive
case saying that this Kherson skull
belongs to me Paige what what's the
third use of apostrophes it's pretty
rare the third use does not happen very
often but apostrophes can occasionally
be used to make words plural okay
because I was always taught never to use
apostrophes to pluralize stuff like the
plural of book is books not books that's
what's wrong yeah so there's no this is
the plural and this is like something
belonging to the book right the books
pages blood yeah right so those there's
really only one case where you want to
use an apostrophe to make something
plural what is that case that case is
when you're trying to make the plural of
a lowercase letter like I'm really bad
at drawing asses right if you didn't
have that apostrophe there it might kind
of just look like so I could say for
example I'm you know I like to draw J's
and remember to dot your J's and eyes
like that to denote that they're plural
to indicate that there's some kind of
separation between this lowercase letter
in this lowercase letter and that we're
trying to say that there are multiple
J's and eyes right and especially with
something like like eyes if you didn't
have that apostrophe there it would
probably just look like you're trying to
write the word is sure so this is kind
of a workaround exactly but this is not
so this usage is extremely rare that's
why I put it in parenthesis because I
just I really want to de-emphasize this
last usage super rare so more
importantly the first two things are the
most important number one contractions
making stuff shorter like I did not eat
the cookie too
I didn't eat the cookie and possession
showing ownership so instead of saying
that person skull belongs to David you
would say that is David's cursed skull
exactly and that's an overview of the
three powers of the apostrophe you can
learn anything
David out page out